we're asked to graph the equation y is
equal to 1/2 times X minus 6 times X
plus 2 and so like always pause this
video and take out some graph paper or
even try to do it on a regular piece of
paper and see if you can graph this
equation alright now let's work through
this together now there are many
different ways that you could attempt to
graph it maybe the most basic is try out
a bunch of X values as a bunch of Y
values and try to connect the curve that
connects all of those dots but let's try
to see if we can get the essence of this
graph without doing that much work and
the key realization here without even
having to do the math is if I multiply
this out if I multiplied X minus 6 times
X plus 2 I'm going to get a quadratic
I'm going to get x squared time plus
something plus something else and so
this whole thing is going to be a
parabola we are graphing a quadratic
equation now a parabola
you might remember can intersect the x
axis multiple times so let's see if we
can find out where this intersects the x
axis and the way the form that it's in
it's in factored form already it makes
it pretty straightforward for us to
recognize when does y equal 0 which are
going to be the times that we're
intersecting the x axis and then from
that we'll actually be able to find the
coordinates of the vertex and we're
going to be able to get the general
shape of this curve which is going to be
a parabola so let's think about it when
does y equal 0 well to solve that we
just have to figure out when if we want
to know when y equals 0 or if we want it
then we have to solve for when is this
expression equal 0 so let's just solve
the equation 1/2 times X minus 6 times X
plus 2 is equal to 0 now in previous
videos we've talked about this idea if I
have the product of multiple things and
it needs to be equal to 0 the only way
that's going to happen is if one or more
of these things are going to be equal to
0 well 1/2 is 1/2 it's not going to be
equal to 0 but X minus 6 could be equal
to 0 so if X minus 6 is equal to 0 then
that would make this equation true
or if X plus 2 is equal to 0 that would
also make
equation true so the X values that
satisfy either of these would make y
equal zero and those would be places
where our curve is intersecting the x
axis so what x value makes X minus six
equals zero well you can add 6 to both
sides
you're probably able to do that in your
head and you get X is equal to 6 or you
subtract 2 to book 4 from both sides
here and you get X is equal to these
cancel out you get X is equal to
negative 2
these are the two X values where Y will
be equal to 0 you can substitute it back
into our original equation if X is equal
to 6 then this right over here is going
to be equal to 0 and then Y is going to
be equal to 0 if X is equal to negative
2 then this right over here is going to
be equal to 0 and Y would be equal to 0
so we know that our parabola is going to
intersect the x-axis at x equals
negative 2 right over there and X is
equal to 6 these are our x-intercepts so
given this how do we figure out the
vertex
well the key idea here is to recognize
that your axis of symmetry for your
parabola is going to sit right between
your two x-intercepts and so what is the
midpoint between or what is the average
of 6 and negative 2 well you can do that
in your head 6 plus negative 2 is 4
divided by 2 is 2 let me do that so I'm
just trying to find the midpoint between
the point there's a new color so I'm
trying to find the midpoint between the
point negative 2 comma 0 and 6 comma 0
well the midpoint those are just the
average of the coordinates the average
of 0 and 0 is just going to be 0 it's
going to sit on the x-axis but then the
midpoint of negative 2 and 6 or the
average negative 2 plus 6 over 2 well
let's see that's 4 over 2 that's just
going to be 2 so 2 comma 0 and you see
that there you might you could have done
that without even doing the math you
think ok if I want to go right in
between the two I want to be 2 away from
each of them and so just like that I
could draw an axis of symmetry for my
parabola and
so my vertex is going to sit on that
axis of symmetry and so how do I know
what the y-value is well I can figure
out I can substitute back in my original
equation say well what is y equal when X
is equal to 2 because remember the
vertex has a coordinate x equals 2 it's
going to be 2 comma something so let's
go back let's see what y equals so Y
will equal to 1/2 x we're going to see
when x equals 2 so 2 minus 6 times 2
plus 2 let's see this is negative 4 this
is positive 4 negative 4 times 4 is
negative 16 so it's equal to 1/2 times
negative 16 which is equal to negative 8
so our vertex when X is equal to 2 y is
equal to negative 8 and so our vertex is
going to be right over here 2 comma
negative 8 and now we can draw the
general shape of our actual parabola
it's going to look something like once
again this is a hand-drawn sketch so
take it with a little bit of a grain of
salt but it's going to look something
like this and it's going to be symmetric
around our axis of symmetry that's why
it's called the axis of symmetry this
art program I have there's a symmetry
tool but I'll just use this and there
you go that's a pretty good sketch of
what this parabola is or what this graph
is going to look like which it is and
open an upward-opening parabola